foreign
[Music]
graphic novels and we've seen them in a
cartoon but we have never seen them in
live actions
to protect the universe these are really
Larger than Life likeable character
there is more to this than me
air razor carries this sense of realness
with her but at the same time she's a
fighter let's get it rhinox is a beast
almost indestructible
my soul everybody it's a sense of family
with the Maximus
all as one
maximals maximized
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things Unicron
is coming
[Music]
back up Oh I thought we were boys
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
yeah baby
thank you
[Music]